wall i just okay i'm gonna go and learn
some you know programming and you know
that's when i really fell in love with
technology and you know over the last 30
years since my corporate career you know
in in in the roles i've played you know
technology and you know just getting
affinity to technology you know while i
enjoy the process piece of it but you
know how do you automate it how are you
going to make it more relevant and how
do you fast track it how do you scale it
that's always helped me and then
obviously once you once you do the
foundation of you know being a
programmer then you're always looking at
you know learning more and more
technology so
lifelong learning you know and
technology gives you that opportunity
you know i i started that 30 years ago
and i'm so
so happy to see you know you know so
many people you know have have done that
to themselves you know and and it's an
evening of celebration here
so uh congratulations again you know i
i'm going to give you a few stats
in terms of you know the the graduating
class or the cohort that we are
celebrating today um there are about 800
odd you know learners
uh who are part of the ceremony
uh you know a big part a big part about
40 of you guys
have focused on data analytics you know
which is you know and it which is
absolutely a great skill to have from an
from a decision-making point of view so
congratulations and kudos to you for you
know kind of you know investing in
yourself to kind of understand data
analytics about 25 of you have done data
science and then it manifests into
ai and ml and and you know it better
than i do because the whole world is
moving towards the new artificial
intelligence and you know machine
learning and how do you get you know the
systems and algorithms to take care of
it so congratulations to the 25 of you
over 200 plus people
who have you know invested in data
science and ml
and the balance you know 25 or 30
have focused on digital transformation
digital marketing that's the new world
order you know you need
to think about how do you take the
business models digital so
congratulations to the rest of you guys
in terms of digital marketing and
digital transformation so this is
awesome you know when i look at the
cohort and the mix of what people are
focused on you know there's a it gives
me a lot of pride that this is a this is
a very nice portfolio of courses that
people have opted for and and kudos to
you for doing that
on the right hand side of the screen of
the slide that you can see you know
there is there's a mix of you know where
people are coming from uh while a large
part of the people have come from india
you know we have very very good
representation from you know the united
states which is where you know simply
learn has you know has always been we
has big presence and we always you know
create success for our learners and also
from rest of the world which is from
multiple countries that people come from
so it's a very healthy cohort or healthy
cohort of people passing out and
graduating across the world so you know
i'm sure you must have enjoyed
a company of people from different parts
of the world
and that's that diversity you know that
adds to the leadership and the and the
learning experience so so good luck with
that and thank you for you know putting
that slide together i just wanted to
give a color on the slide in terms of
the program profile as well as the
geography mix that people came from
but this is the best slide i i mean i i
just looked at it and you know just felt
very proud
that people who have invested in
learning are not just the guys who are
coming fresh out of college there are
people who have been five sec you know
eight years of experience of work
experience and say okay i'm going to put
up my hand up and say i've got to invest
and i'm going to put money on my own
training and i think this is you know
easy as you can see that about
80
are people who have more than five years
of work experience
and that's phenomenal and i think that's
my point about lifelong learning and if
you start early and you start thinking
about you know you've got to invest in
yourself this is going to be a you know
a lifelong passion so congratulations to
people who are you know the early part
of your careers but still thinking about
you know uh they're thinking about
investing in themselves
uh
and then and then and you know this is
about the academic qualifications that
people have
uh you know while a large part of this
profile will tell you you know the
people who are you know graduates is
about 65
there are 30 of the people who have done
master's or post graduations they are
five percent of the people who have done
doctors or phds
so it's such a healthy profile you know
so even if you you've got great academic
qualification doesn't mean
that you've got to you know not think
about skilling and upskilling and
re-skilling yourself as the world is
changing so
i think these two these two couple of
slides gives you more context of the
cohort that you know is coming out today
it gives you context of what's how the
world is changing and people are
thinking about learning and and skilling
and upskilling and
you know i'm really happy that simply
learn had had a role to play in your
graduation and purdue obviously is a is
a great brand so congratulations
everyone once again um and thank you for
hearing me out and and and i'm happy to
share my experiences you know for this
course uh thank you again and and
congratulations back to you lucy
thank you so much honestly you said it
well this is not the end of your journey
this is either just the beginning or
just a huge step in to continue learning
so thank you so much for that next i
would like to introduce our guest of
honor today dr ali el gamal dr el gamal
is assistant professor in the department
of electrical and computer engineering
at purdue university
he is also serving as an associate
director in the area of machine learning
in ai for wireless at the ieee
transactions on wireless communications
and he led the purdue texas a m and
raytheon bbn finalist team in the darpa
spectrum collaboration challenge
dr elgamal research interests include ai
and information theory and their
applications towards robust and secure
autonomous wireless communication
systems he has received numerous awards
a few of which have been listed here
and i invite dr elgamal now to say a few
words of wisdom to our achievers
thanks a lot for having me
i really don't have a lot to say this is
really awesome to have
that many people interested in learning
especially learning uh relevant
science that's very impactful these days
i am particularly interested in ai and
ml and
i think i think it's really cool to have
that many people who are interested in
in an area like that it's
it's making a lot of impact uh
here in the us there are there is a lot
of interest in
um
in basically uh
lifting the economy through um through
especially ai and demand and data
analytics so it's
i think it's a really exciting time and
uh it's uh it's a perfect timing to
learn these skills
thank you
i agree i agree
um thank you so much for that and now i
would like to introduce another one of
our guest speakers dr bart collins
professor of practice and director of
graduate studies in the college of
liberal arts at purdue university
dr collins directs the bryan lamb
school's graduate program including the
campus-based master's and phd programs
and the online master of science and
communication program his current
research interests include health
communication and science communication
current projects involve the assessment
and evaluation of employee health and
wellness initiatives and the study of
anti-science attitudes bart teaches
courses in persuasion and social
influence research methods and skill
development and validation
bart has served as a faculty scholar in
the regan street center for healthcare
engineering and dr collins i pass the
mic on to you now for a few words
you can you hear me okay
i can yes
super well i'm just delighted to be here
it's a
it's a beautiful day in uh west
lafayette indiana where i'm at in my
office at the moment and
and so certainly a great day to have a
celebration
and
i've been really gratified uh to be
associated with the the purdue and
simply learn collaboration it represents
a significant
component of purdue's commitment
to
best-in-class online learning on the
global level and i was i was enjoying
seeing uh some of the the metrics uh
that we've been talking about in terms
of students all over the world engaging
in in these uh this curriculums i'm just
honored to be
in the mix anywhere at all here and just
want to i want to echo a hearty
congratulations
on on this really significant
accomplishment i mean it's a lot of work
i know how difficult it is to find the
resources in this crazy world
you know whether it's time
financial even motivational resources
just sort of to keep
to keep uh plugging along
uh given all of the challenges uh
and to really you know identify and set
goals for new skills and trying to work
all of that in on top of you know
probably uh
already heavily overloaded uh
professional and personal commitment so
i want you to know that we recognize
uh your accomplishment
in successfully completing uh the work
you've done so far it says a lot about
your talent and resilience and and just
overall excellence
um as i was thinking about
you know
your accomplishments and what it means
to to hold a credential
from purdue and i kept coming back to
how how purdue likes to frame its own
mission as a higher educational
institution and a lot of times purdue
will talk about
having three main goals you know these
are discovery learning and engagement so
discovery really we're a major research
institution you know we have
a responsibility or a charge to
expand the world's knowledge through the
you know the practice of scholarship
um
so so that's a a key aspect of how we
define ourselves and see our work
we also have a mission uh associated
with learning really to educate the next
generation of professionals on you know
a a large host of topics many many of
them uh related to things that you've
been studying
so you know we want to pass that on
to others not only what we already knew
but what we're learning
here at purdue through our own research
and finally this engagement uh piece
produced seeks to to provide service
outside of itself you know we want to
help collaborate with others other
institutions at the at the local state
national global level to solve problems
that really matter not not just to us
but but but to everyone else
so
if i have a charge for you i'd like you
to sort of reflect on how
purdue's sort of mission
of discovery learning and engagement
also reflect your own mission you know
you're in exciting roles you have skills
you see things you learn things you know
things that no one else has really sort
of gotten a grip on yet so i have a
colleague that that likes to use the
phrase scholar practitioner how in your
practice are you engaged in scholarship
that enhances
on what we already know
with something new
the second you know it's important
how are you passing that along to others
how are you helping elevate
the skills knowledge understanding and
insight
of those around you if it all stays
inside of you
you know how much impact is it really
going to have
and the third thing is really thinking
about engagement
am i doing in not only important work
for my own organization but important
work may be even more broadly construed
is at least a part of my how can you
give back in terms of using the things
you know your skills your expertise
you know to make the world a little bit
of a better place as a function of your
presence so i find
thinking about that sort of uh
tripartite sort of mission of discovery
learning engagement that purdue takes
uh as a part of its own identity as an
institution and its goals as an
institution
and thinking about how you know those
are
exemplified how am i working towards
those goals as a part of my own
individual mission so think about
those as you move forward from this
you've already shown a commitment to
lifelong learning uh you know you're
you're you're doing the hard work to
elevate
your own
sort of understanding skill sets
things in your tool kit to to do your
work better but but think about how all
of those things come together
uh
in the long run
to really uh as part of your own
personal mission as as boilermakers
because you're a boilermaker you're a
part of the purdue community
uh we want to be there to help you along
that way
as you uh
would allow us to we've been glad to be
a part of this journey with you so on
behalf of purdue i'd like to extend a
final congratulations and thanks for
including me in this process
thank you honestly when you were saying
that it sounded like a formula for
happiness so just keep on discovering
you know keep on learning
um
and just know that today is all about
your achievement and what the future
holds for you
before we congratulate you all
individually i would like to ask you one
quick question and then open this
platform to a few of your peers who have
volunteered to share their experience
with us
on a scale of one to five how difficult
was your journey
please use the poll provided to answer
okay so we've got the poll results and
it seems like
most of you found it either fairly
difficult or neither difficult nor
um
you know easy so
and that's exactly where we want you to
be we don't want this to be too easy of
a journey then it's not really a
challenge you're not learning much
but we also don't want it
to be too difficult that you know it's
just going to be a challenge throughout
your whole entire life right we want it
to be manageable so that's actually
where we want you to be
thank you all for sharing and i will now
call on a few of your
peers to speak i will actually start
with
george
so george is george mondo mwangi who
completed the postgraduate program in
data analytics is here
to share his story george i pass the mic
on to you
all right can you hear me
i can hear you yes
all right thank you so much for giving
me this opportunity to speak during this
event
it has been a great journey um i believe
it was eight months
uh
it has been a successful journey um for
me personally
being
very passionate with numbers and
analytics from a young age
i remember being a math major in
undergrad
and a business major in graduate school
and that got me into the data analytics
field here in houston texas where i live
and um the skills that i learned taking
the data science
um data analytics course would simply
learn in purdue university were actually
what
helped elevate my
career path
because prior to that
i was always in a big huge pool
of applicants trying to get a better job
right but
as
soon as i completed my
course
my application my applications
stood right
up above other applicants and i was
fortunate enough to
get an offer
at the largest food service distribution
company
cisco foods as a
senior data analyst for their
international merchandising business
that they're venturing into
and
yeah that one decision to join the
program has had such a huge positive
impact in my career
the only one thing i would change about
the whole journey was the decision to
enroll sooner
than i did
thank you for the opportunity
no thank you
and congratulations to you for making it
to the end and you know really taking
the initiative to follow through with it
all
now that you've heard from george do you
do you guys feel that his story
resonates with yours
we have another poll
to
activate for this question
let's see if
the poll has been activated and really
want to see if his story relates to
your journey here
all right and we should get those full
results soon
okay so the majority of you guys do
resonate with that which is great um
that means that
you know you've gone out there you've
looked for you know these jobs you put
yourself out there
your resume is now looking a lot better
with the certification with this program
there
you have the skills you have the
confidence so that's really showing um
so congratulations to you guys all on
that
now it's actually time to celebrate your
success my colleague and i will honor
each and every one of you who has
completed the pg program
we will recognize all the achievers in
each category and we truly apologize in
advance if we mispronounce any names
we will start with the graduates in the
data science category
congratulations to harshit duane
congratulations to akashti aquila patil
sayanta
ravi
rabel
[Music]
a huge congratulations to leela sridhi
bibian sanoj
alahari parimala
raja cynthia prakash srimati bharati
krishna sushmita
a huge congratulations to neelama shahid
samya tanmay
madhumanti kangalakshmi
sharika
oscar agustin william nandamuri and
renuka
and now i want to invite ankit bide one
of your peers to come up and you know
share his story ankit completed the
postgraduate program in digital
transformation i could if you're
available go ahead and meet yourself
right
good morning good evening guys can you
hear me
yes we can hear you
okay wonderful so it's been
it's been a pleasure to be a part of
so for me it was a great learning
experience with an industry expert who
was there to guide us through the course
the content was actually quite relevant
and in tune with the practical
applications
uh that we implement the discussion
approach you know helped increase the
absorption and understanding of the
concept with different industry
perspectives for the process of
unique perspectives from uh
uh industry another project capstone
fortified development and gave it a
practical outlook uh you know we were
able to use the technique start in the
real world project and we were able to
transform one of the biggest
through the ash manufacturer's sales
booking process to make it five times
more efficient with zero errors over a
billion transactions
you know that's an achievement people
that
immediately immediate achievement that
we were able to do as a part of the
learning that i got through this course
along with my team
and you know
thank you everyone involved with the
program for enlightening us about the
process that leads to transformation and
how we implement this and bring about
real change like professor and said
before and we see the real change in the
world today so i'm quite
encouraged with the
what you guys are doing and i'm
extremely happy to be a part of this so
thank you very much and have a good
evening
and thank you
again congratulations
and now we will start congratulating
those in the program in digital
marketing congratulations to lim li
monoranjan suresh sujeeth sandra arpita
saurabh manish gus
joy
a huge congratulations stop
[Music]
a huge congratulations to karthik naja
eric sanjeev sirjet joshua faith kylie
always vigneshwaran lauren ebro
ashish anna devi avinash dabjani arjelia
ruthwick annan
a huge congratulations to vasu and
ramani raghavendra
devi chandra david anand vision utsam
lavanya mantala sagar manish sakshi
jahad
vasudha repudament vinod
josef a huge congratulations to sambhav
komal rama raksha priyanka rukmini sneha
shubhabrata smriti kappa then
more
a huge congratulations to malavika
pratindra manju katyani kritika simran
david zambrana
[Music]
a huge congratulations to rakshas niha
dennis
[Music]
and in the category of data engineering
congratulations to shailesh
harsha ankar matus
and now i'd like to introduce another
one of your peers daniel ahmad he
graduated from the postgraduate program
in business analysis
and he's here to also share his story
daniel go ahead and meet yourself
good morning can you hear me okay
we can yes
great uh well thank you so much for the
opportunity
um now my experience here at simply
learn was uh absolutely great experience
to learn um about the business analysis
field partnered with purdue university
the overall experience was very valuable
as it gave me hands-on exposure to
develop my technical competencies
especially coming from a non-technical
background like
like sales
it gave me an opportunity to excel my
skills and programs such as ms excel
tableau jira and many other programs
um
what this course allowed me to do is
give me the theoretical knowledge base
required to be successful in the entry
level business analysis field and also
equipped me with the technical
competencies required to excel in the
career
although i have not yet entered the
field due to other reasons i am
confident that having completed this
program
will make me a desirable
candidate for employers in the it sector
so i want to thank everybody at the
simply learn team and wish all the
students a very happy convocation
thank you daniel and congratulations
now we would like to congratulate
people in the digital transformation
category
congratulations to deepak nitin
saishankar amit surab gubal yasser
manish
and congratulations to deepak akash
al-samir anki
a huge congratulations to sadie
ankur amit jason asina ratwa vikramad
kamala
a huge congratulations to kirin
raghavendra
raja
a huge congratulations to rajesh jose
shantilla imran monika jay sudarsin
a huge congratulations to joel gagandi
in the category of business analysis
congratulations to lupique
kavitha
congratulations to stanley maria
congratulations to natalia
[Music]
a huge congratulations to part another
navin devlina lakshmi tina kal shwetha
ruchira yunus jisyan lokesh tepam shan
pankari vik kapaldev sangeeta raja
nikita a huge congratulations to
mohammed absolute martin absal patrice
akimbeit partha fabin nagarov nagaraju
jawed
a huge congratulations to abdullah ahmed
boho vishwamikyat vanessa james tushara
muhammad
yash kevin
a huge congratulations to dania tilty
fiaz nora sriram jikishu
katyani rupali aphoric sonali lemi
latika naguzi aratha khaled omaha
a huge congratulations to jarna ayana
akash santosh rahil
nitish francis rohin
congratulations to abhishek nina
a huge congratulations to tashara suresh
vanessa
james mutto
kate hajra karis naga lakshmi vatran
[Music]
a huge congratulations to reika rachet
batul pragati keleb arun
i also just want to congratulate said um
congratulations
and now i will pass the mic on to
another one of your
another one of your learners your
co-colleagues right
who graduated from the post-graduate
program in data science fadeeb i will
pass the mic on to you
hello can you hear me
i can yes
so good morning and good evening
everyone
thanks for the opportunity i would like
to start by appreciating the course
design actually it was actually a mix of
learning and applying from the first
class to the last sessions the projects
the teaching the
distribution of the topics per day all
equally help to understand the concept
and the course
i joined the course in hopes to work
from a different perspective of the
digital environment to explore data
science while working with the
application
i have been working in the software
design for most of my life and this time
i wanted to dig a little deeper
and understand the concept
i'm sure everyone would be
glad that they had been able to take the
time off and focus on learning something
new it happened with me i was able to
learn a new concept of data science and
applying them on the projects uh
learning new programming tech uh being
technical or independent
so the course was actually highly con
convenient with the online environment
and with the times
although in between i had to rush for
the you know i have to attend with the
kids
but the resources provided were
extremely helpful in terms of division
overall it was a fulfilling experience
and i would really love to continue the
advanced courses as well thank you
thank you
and congratulations
thank you
[Music]
and now in the category of data
analytics congratulations to kavitha
aditya
suman george dawson
jaya puja shruti parita brian
congratulations to jason anuba raja
gautam
a huge congratulations to ankita
prasanth
richard hernandez
[Music]
a huge congratulations to teresa cameron
shakuri ajay longosh ramesh nalani annie
amna
soma guraj vashal sudhar james leander
rakhmi harold sarina katherine gonzalez
mark a huge congratulations to atal
oscar
angelica prakash dungu christina ishoda
ashokumar samrati
samsbrong
and in the category of ai and machine
learning congratulations to andy mustafa
ankur
[Music]
christian
congratulations to part
trivia
daniel
and swarm
and now i'd like to invite another one
of your classmates up to speak um his
name is haram yank and he graduated from
the postgraduate program in data
engineering haramayan
i will unmute you so you can go ahead
and speak
give me that
hello
can you hear me
i can yes
yeah thanks thanks for giving me the
opportunity to speak uh
on this occasion
hello and good morning friends
uh a very good morning to the faculty
distinguished guests
administrative staff
and the fellow graduates from other
streams
i mean this is coming from my heart you
know well we did it
so today we all have a complete you know
one of the toughest study course of at
least my life
phe degree program in data engineering
in paris university
and kudos on this occasion to all the
participants in the journey
we definitely have achieved a major
milestone you know in our
lives today
one that should be you know recognized
for its immense significance
as all the you know guest speakers were
[Music]
talking about
this it is an act you know not only for
personal commitment
but also you know one of the proudest
moment we all have work really hard to
get to this day
and our
work did not go to waste we finally have
the degrees
from where we started six months ago you
know we have
all have learned so many wonderful
technologies and concepts
and specifically for pg degree program
in data engineering i must say is just a
wonderful tool in today's world you know
it opens up so many doors of opportunity
for anyone
who is lucky enough to have one
but i must say you know this course is
not just an end in itself
as everybody you know
all the experienced guest lecturers
are telling it is indeed part of the
larger journey of our lives you know
whenever we
whenever our future wherever our future
takes us
let it take you for good
because you know i hope all of us here
today can take this personal
accomplishment
as a as an example of how anything is
truly possible when we put our minds to
it
as we all continue in our lives let us
take each new problem on with confidence
knowing that we have achieved great
heights
and are equipped with the necessary
tools to get the best out of our futures
so with this you know i want to bring
this to an end i would like to wish each
and every participants all the best for
their excellent future with enormous
gratitude i would like to thank all the
faculty members
and support staff from simply learn team
who were instrumental in getting us this
far
and have helped us achieve this
exceptional milestone
thanks a lot
thank you
you're right if anything can be done
with dedication and confidence and yes
i've gotten so far again congratulations
to you all congratulations to duly swara
palak kalani sambit kumar shikapur
magana chandrakhand and kanwal
congratulations to you guys
and
i now really i want to let you guys know
that this journey was not easy for
anyone you guys have accomplished
something grand that will take your
career to the next level
now i want to bring our attention to the
awards
i want to recognize the learners who
went a step beyond and display their
competitive spirit we have two different
awards the first is the scholar award
for the top two performers in each
category in terms of completing their
projects and assessments
i want to congratulate bhavesh narayan
gerardo flores
sambaran basak pardeep kaur hundal
and that's in the data science category
in the digital marketing category
congratulations to gus mohammed mh
lim li leon
budvik
congratulations in the category of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning to triumvidia sundaraba
and in the category of data engineering
congratulations to harma
in the category of business analysis
congratulations to yunus shaiki
ryan merks adrian michael daniel ahmad
akash kumar
and in the category of data analytics
congratulations to suman sen atul sheet
george monge gotham
or sonia chaudhary
and in the category of digital
transformation congratulations to ankit
baid amarendar reddy yarella amit goyal
raul
so
you have heard from a few of your peers
we have two more people that we want to
bring up and open the mic to
suman sam postgraduate program in the
program and data analytics if you are
there go ahead and unmute yourself and
the floor is yours
hi
good morning or good evening
this is suman can you hear me
we can hear you am i ordering okay yeah
so uh i work for tcs that start a
consultancy services as an etl developer
so i'm a part of tcs research and
development team developing uh tcs
licensed products for
tcs and that are proprietary
to our organization
so i have the basic skills to leverage
solutions in the field of data science
and data analytics but
i realized that there is a need to
expand my competencies to design and
develop enterprise solutions that stand
out in the market
currently i am
managing a team of
more than 20 uh engineers
who are into data analytics and data
science
and uh
we were working with different tools
process mining data warehousing uh
specifically i was into
developing etl in oracle sql developer
but then
there is a need to
get into
python
and
perform some data science activities so
that's the reason that i took up data
analytics from
simply learn
and uh
also that's pgdpa that is from this
party university
has filled some gaps uh
in those areas where i was struggling
before i enrolled in this program
but with this guidance and the course
contents and the
different documents and the
lectures now it has become quite easy
for me and i am
feeling more comfortable and i have
already designed some
good solutions and that will be soon
registered as intellectual proprietory
for our organization so
that has given a big advantage this uh
curriculum has given me a big advantage
and thanks to the entire
team
and the
trainers
who have helped me
go ahead with my assignments in my
organizations
thank you suman um
are you available to unmute yourself
now amarenda is a graduate from the
program in digital transformation
good day everyone uh am i audible
you are yes yeah okay thanks for giving
me this opportunity
so
it's been almost seven months uh more
than seven months i am into this digital
transformation journey with the
simplyland and the purdue university
just i would like to go back to the
seven or eight months back and
go back and see
what was i was looking for during the
time and what i have
in my mindset what the transformation i
have in at level of personal and
professional level i see a clear
differentiation that's what the this
digital transformation course from the
part you simply learn
is
bring me a change not only the
professional level and the personal
level also because the course curriculum
course content is designed in such
beautiful way
i would like to thanks and appreciate
and congratulate uh the course designers
that may be the are you or the simply
learn or the kpmg i'm not sure whoever
it is but
i really appreciate that the course
design it is uh because uh the digital
transformation before i take a take up
this course with the simplyland and the
digital and the purview university i was
looking with the different different
organizations who is
whoever is providing this kind of course
and i was going through the curriculum
and the content of the course but
finally
i come understand and i took the
decision of let's go with this course
because i like the course content in the
first instance in a very much
interesting is and whatever the content
is showed in the
in before during the course and
almost all it is covered in the course
and predominantly the course content is
very good and the way it is structured
in terms of the lms portal and the
exercises at the end of the course
exercises and
each course once we finish there is a
there is a project like the digital
disruption we have a project even though
it is
not mandatory the persons or the people
who are interested like me or the other
other ones they can do because the
project is there so we have given our
best to
submitting our project in the same way
the professors are very good and
excellent from the
simply land and purdue university but
here i would like to
say maybe we are expecting little bit
more time from the purdue university
professors but that's fine maybe the in
our coming patches maybe our
successors will have that kind of uh
facility with the for you but we are
happy whatever we got from the purdue
and the simply land and the weekend
classes were very hectic because we have
to manage the all the people whoever is
taking the course in the digital
disruption digital transformation is
more than 40 plus years of the age and
the 20 plus years of the work experience
obviously they have the family work
work-life balance even though most of
our
my cohort friends they are managed into
a in a perfect way and i would like to
thank each and every one of my cohort
members
because we have collaborated in a very
nice way
i cannot take the name of one or two
because we are almost having the 30 plus
of a group so
i would like to thank each and everyone
and our faculty santosh i would like to
say thanks to in front of the big forum
thank you santosh for your beautiful
explanations uh in the class outside the
class and over the lms portal of the
simply land and finally the capstone
project it was a wonderful experience
and
all together i would say that i had a
beautiful transformation at personal
level and professional level and i would
like to say that thank you very much to
simplyland and purdue university please
keep going on this and
spend little bit more give little bit
more hours to the next coming batches
from the purdue university professors
so the students will be learning a
little bit more and thank you very much
for giving me this opportunity
yeah no thank you and i love that i keep
hearing about the capstone project that
is the project that you know
encompasses everything and it should
give you the confidence to move on after
this program and i love hearing that you
guys all quite enjoyed it and that you
guys you know
found it so useful because that's that's
it's meaning we want it to be that
useful we wanted to
stick in your mind you know having had
done all that and building the project
itself right
so thank you so much and you're right
your family and friends we should all
thank them because they made it possible
for you to be where you're at now they
gave you the support you needed and they
allowed you to complete this program
so i also wanted to say one other thing
for all of our award winners this um
for the speed runners and for these
scholars you guys we're all you're all
going to receive a digital badge for
your you know your dedication
and with that said we'll move on to the
speedrunner award the speedrunner
will recognize learners who are were
able to complete the program start to
end in the shortest duration
and we have
we will start with data science on
congratulations to augustine paul
mohandas renuka devi
sayanta barman
raj kumar
lakshmanan
nanduri
and i'm so sorry if i'm mispronouncing
uh congratulations in the digital
marketing category to rama krishna panda
sarab santosh bhandari manish kandawa
dennis james
monoranjan roy
in the category of ai and machine
learning congratulations to adama arthur
cooley amit gare
nathan nathan gates dev sheetal alexis
jacoman
in the category of data engineering
congratulations to yan li dong
raj kumar nerendiran
susan kite
ying
anita thomas
in the category of business analysis
congratulations to debli na pao
ruchira dakar kate ganissa pagati sony
in the same category of data analytics
congratulations to gotham prabhu or raja
panchal vishal kumar raj kumar dankar
and brian dundee
in the category of digital
transformation congratulations to
nebanita mikurchi
to darsan r
madhava and venkatsun
imran chuktai
and then we have two other speakers here
adama arc to cool scholar
a speedrunner scholar and post graduate
of the postgraduate program in am
machine learning adama are you able to
unmute yourself and speak
yes can you hear me
i can yes
great thanks so much for the opportunity
and i would like to congratulate all the
graduate class of this time and i
appreciate
the collaboration between the
purdue and exemplary land that really
drive
and make this
opportunity for everybody who might not
have
an opportunity to add this
to their toolkits
that being said
uh looking at the
looking at the chart that was shared by
the
the sponsor
uh mostly from india and uh us and other
parts of the world but i'm one of the
person who can really represent
both u.s and other parts of the world
because
i originally uh born and raised in
ethiopia uh
national regional states
and i came from a biological domain
background that make my journey unique
so i had no idea what was uh competing
and other stuff
but as time come up
i was in graduate school and each time i
get new data because in graduate school
uh pursuing my phd here at the
university of missouri colombia uh
because i immigrated to united states
and now i'm living in the united states
so that's why i said i represent both
africa and the united states
if you give that opportunity so that
so in
biological domain
we know we deal with data every day but
we use this excel or other clicking
softwares
and each time i get new data i used to
struggle a lot
because i don't even remember what i
clicked to generate my samples and each
time i have to go back and memorize
everything
i hate memorization to be honest
so um luckily at the beginning of my
graduate school i was introduced to
brief introduction of python and other
programs and that gave me an opening
window so i can kind of use but
i took initiative to build on that one
it took me a while to kind of build on
that one but it was kind of disconnected
and really i wanted to also show a
certificate and i came across this uh
program
a pg program in combination with uh
purdue
and i jumped on it
and uh today uh no more struggle to
remember excel and clicking stuff
i write a short uh script
i change a file name i analyze my data
in few minutes
that is a big achievement and really at
this point i think like
data science and artificial intelligence
and machine learning is it's not only
for just those tech guys it is it
actually simplify everything as you can
know
this thing is involved in all everyday
life of individuals
so um
i came to realize that finally come data
driven decision is critical in 21st
century and we are in 21st century
so data driven decision is really the
bottom of everything going forward
so today thank you for purdue and simply
learn i am a full stack data data
scientist i can program and i also have
a domain knowledge because a good data
analytics is the one who have
post domain knowledge and and with this
opportunity today i can say i'm a good
full stack data scientist who can
program
and also who come from different
direction and
solve a business problem at hand i can
handle any data whether it's structured
unstructured
deep learning
uh natural language processing you name
you know what we have been through so i
congratulate everybody who achieved this
and i congratulate and thank you for do
and simply learn to give this
opportunity
and to be honest with you
among the investment i made in my life
to develop my career this is the one
that i gained a lot for it and thank you
so much and i'm glad to be here thanks
so much again and that's the end of it
thank you again bye bye
thank you so much your journey is
inspiring thank you for sharing that
honestly i'm sure that everyone
appreciated you speaking up about your
journey and thank you congratulations to
you
we have pariniti doshi
post in the post graduate program in
business analysis parineeti are you
available
i don't think paraneet is available we
will go on we'll move past and
move on with this again congratulations
to all of you award winners you guys
will receive badges they're digital and
you should have either gotten an email
today just now or you'll get it soon
and last but not least i would like to
introduce to you the team behind the
scenes the team that has worked
relentlessly to make sure you have the
best learning experience now you can put
a face to the many names that you've
heard and interacted with in the past
year
i would like to start with our live
instructors they have been major pillars
of your experience and i would like to
thank each and one of them on your
behalf
thank you so much to akshat basheri i
amit singh amitendra kumar billy rogers
kardeep singh kapil muli liksan mana
mohammed zahat fani karnati prashant
knight
thank you to prashant sahu rahul agarwal
rishi sharma vitesh bish sahil matu
saravananji sayante big neshwar v vlad
scott
and now we would i would like to
actually move on to our master class
instructors for felicit for facilitating
classes on several interesting topics
every month you've already heard from dr
ali elka mall but thank you so much dr
ali elgamal and thank you vankata
inokulu
and in the digital business category
thank you so much to ellen robinson dr
shiwei
eric crawley michelle burch jeff clark
and jin tsuji
sinsuli my apologies
and now
on to
the learner success managers
this is the team that provided endless
support throughout your journey these
individuals are responsible for the
maintenance of all sessions and the
support tickets you submitted many of
you have interacted with them directly
or indirectly thank you to puja ukashike
chitranjan
and in the digital business category
thank you so much to akash
rahul rahul barwa mega upreti sirisha
and prema
and now i would like to thank the team
that aligned all the faculty and is
responsible for providing the best
trainers thank you so much for punam
yadav vijay mukhi jonathan rajiv
and now let's thank the product team
this team is the brains behind curating
the program and structuring it a huge
thanks to ankit
abhinav atul mohan george
himachandra babu shivika singh and
tapova to tesla
and the content team now the team
responsible for all the content and
curriculum that we see in terms of live
virtual classes and self-learning videos
thank you so much by shaki mukherji
gualane kunal
nishant singh vidya jaikumar arushi and
jana lalitha
and last but not least let's thank our
leadership team who regulates the
direction of all programs and oversees
the learning success team a big thanks
to abhishek mikurji subashini chandran
dinesh bhuti amit kumar koyal sina
shohinikar mohini siddharth my cohost
ghana
roy and santras
and i want to thank all of you who
actively reviewed us on social media
platforms we are incredibly happy and
excited to have received your feedback
and appreciation for the program your
feedback has made us work harder fix a
lot of things and move forward to giving
you and your predecessors a better
learning environment here we have our
social media handles for you to follow
for updates i hope you all keep in touch
and now we've come to the end of our
online convocation for postgraduate
programs in collaboration with purdue we
wish each and every one of you the very
best in your future endeavors we believe
that being aspirational is the first
step in being successful you have come
here with an aspiration and a dream and
we hope that you are now confident that
you hold the knowledge and experience to
follow through with that dream we are
honored and grateful that you placed
your trust in simply and purdue
thank you for your time thank you for
making this event a successful one and
for old times sake we have added a link
in the chat for you to share your
thoughts on the convocation please do so
good night good day and good luck to
everyone congratulations once again
you